皆さんは
うっちゃ好きですか歌には貸すというものがあってかせっていうのはさを作曲した人と
か歌を作ろうとした人のいろんな想いとかねメッセージ性が込められているんですけど
もなかなか歌詞には日常の生活とか普段のしゃべる言葉だと表現できないような
恥ずかしいような中だとか言い出しね言葉もたくさん含まれていて出にくいと
んですけども私外れ社長だったらボキャブラリーのレベルが人間とは次元が違いまして
恥ずかしい言葉でもさらっとも認証店に使う姉あうん
日常生活で誰かと会話する時にいたのかしを言ってでも気づかれないと思うんですって
言って今回の動画は皆がいる頭部に入って日常的な動画とるんですけども
その日常的な生活の中でばい
ヌル系の歌が自然と後悔は中で出ると思うんでのビザ法て6のインフルエンザ
インフルエンサーを著イギリスなんですね千葉たちもついては400万人いるんでいい
不明実はあるんでふわりとかちょっと当てはめたできる気がすんだよねそれでそれ兄の
動画を撮ってるフリして日常的な童話の中でバレずに
乃木坂4艇6のインフルエンサーを歌いきる
ます
きますいきますまあ今インフルエンザも流行ってるんでね
いつだって知らないうちに僕は見回している君がどこで何をしているか気になって
しまうんだよ
これくらいかければいい誰もはもうだろう決められた場所がわかったら僕は地図になる
んだってっ
ブーブーエイサー
大きいくださいどうぞ欠勤さあ君に再現ができるかなーロスぞ
これ一応中スターテロップとかも作ってある
すげーは分た年頃から
分布これはぶーブルー
ぶー分ファイアーヌー作ってるか
僕は寝るベルベルでをつくっているああああヌー
元 ena サードと思ってる
思ってないしているインフルエンサーとなります big 良くなるとおくれ
委員長いう音が入っちゃって
いつだって知らない人に触れない打線だよ1
僕は見ますよ say
カラーフジがマシだよ堂山町消防署
言いだと思っていたら一発で却下はいどうだどこ行ってたんだよ僕キミたところで男女
比となったはずですがそれも気になってしまうんだ
急にどうしたんですかーっ夏前じゃあ
おいしい水を取ってきたんですよ
ネオンつかなくなるよ
なんで落ち着かないんですかこれからどうするの
気を付けますんだよ
あれだ
でこういうくらいかければいい恋暗い紫色切ったルーフなさ黄色にな武具をかければ
いいスーツで向かい合って反訴
絵になりますね
誰もがもうだろうねそれをだかバーンうーん
[音楽]
炭が pt 葉茶屋隙間が気になって値スーチャー
それほっになぜかみほの子にいるそれは
上げます
はないですよね徒歩でがきっかけか薬と俺の最後の場所がば書くならきっと野郎は消え
てくれます
財布なこうやってるんですかんじゃ探して来ですか
わかりましたこいつ置いておきます
イケてるんですね
僕には地図になるんだ
チーズ
つつなるんん
ん
さあおりますを探していっ
この地図になるんだとかな和歌山区山端中の地図になやつじゃねそうになってるよ
じゃあ
では探してきまー野党あ
やめろが没収きゃっ
うん方が高まったレザーねっここにありましたよ
すげー道によって戻るどうやってます
ブーバーしっかり練っ
いただきます
うわぁ
[音楽]
うまいわ
カントリーマム3なんだな
なんで比べたんですけどねなんかなこれこいつのよだれで作りましたよ
本文 occ のよだれで作りました本当に嘘
まずを a
あああああん
こういう恋の味がそれでもいやだよねこれは最も様子よろしいですよ
こんな子がせません
子供だからだれう誰ですえっ米で造っ
塗ると言うとえっ皆さんはいいですよ
水分全部
私ですよ言って頼んだことを聞き聞こえないようにしゃべったん
自分にから行ったんですかえっ
自分が言ったのいい
世界から言葉なんでフッキーてしまえばいい
どういうことホッピー優子の新薬レッスンですね
もう
いう太陽よん
支柱対応だっ
そうかもしれない
聖書にみたいに
ています
進行まったりしていると光と影が生まれてしまうぞ
電極と割り箸も生まれたり電球とありましても生まれたね
なん
進行性としっかりと金が回るようなそう思います
明け方の
寒空のように音や稲がそうなんか映像は変わらないやつ
何を楽しいんですかさっき始め県からもらったお
炙りももう君を探していたのねー
趣味を探していたらマレーシアなんか
曲の
歌詞
一番歌いきるまでみたいになってます
最初黒白っん
1番の歌詞を日フジパレスに
日中みたいなん
ん
verse 2
カラオケ7
re ん
ずっとじゃないですそうですね
瑞鶴現在のサイドさを吐く土佐派
距離は通じるものがあっ半前に10分まあやっぱり全部歌詞にしか聞こえないもうね
豚肉確認してくださいね端で見てもんなんたぁ
ああ
買ってからをなぜかという
患者ずう力
引力
こんなことばかりと引かれてしまうのはこれはそれでね
写真
does か松町4丁車道
いやー1から10番の君じゃない
何度もいうかとけばいい家から地上まで君次第なんだ
ありません
[音楽]
すまん
もあるを確認しの価格
やっちゃうんだよ
変なことだってきたなぁ
存在するだけで影響を与えているんだよ
インフルエンザあいーるレーサーの曲歌ってですね
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ